she was there for every single important
thing we do and I'm not sure how we do
it without her we're in the middle of
yet another Kamala rescue mission two
months after the last effort failed the
White House is once again leaning on its
media allies to pump her up ahead of
2024. now the latest piece is framing
her as a fighter
I guess for killing babies what the road
decision saw Harris become the bite
administration's foremost voice on
Reproductive Rights it was that intense
level of passion that finally gave
Harris something that she'd been
searching for a clear and unambiguous
mission on which she could lead
so are all these common Resurrection
efforts helping well apparently not
because a brand new NBC News poll is
revealing that her net negative rating
of -17 that's right near where Putin is
Andre the lowest for any vice president
in the polls history joining me now Ned
Ryan American majority CEO Ned what is
this so her big mission was the border
right she was going to take care of the
border now her mission is what you know
make sure we have more abortions in the
United States because that's the
permanent platform of the Democrat Party
yay she just keeps going about border AI
now abortions are I thought the funniest
thing about that poll uh Laura was the
fact that she was beaten by Darth Vader
AKA Dick Cheney by 40 points on the net
favorability rating and if you're if
you're getting crushed by Darth Vader
you might have a likability problem just
throwing that out but but think about it
Kamala was not chosen because she was
bright and likable I mean I I think the
Democratic voters in the primary 2020
primary made that very clear she didn't
even make it to Iowa but she was chosen
because she checked a few boxes first
she she they had to choose somebody to
be Biden's VP who would never outshine
him intellectually and she has
demonstrated her great capabilities at
doing that she's an overachiever on that
front and she also checks the
politically correct box of being a black
woman
um so if you think about that as of
those as being her qualifications uh to
be Biden's VP she she has really hit it
out of the park on all fronts gold stars
all around I think the real question on
this Laura is what if Biden doesn't run
I think he still is I think Joe Biden's
going to be dragging and propping up
that empty husk as long as she can but
if he doesn't run I think Kamal is a
bridge too far even for Democrats but
then what do you do you can't push aside
a black woman for a White Guy say Gavin
Newsom I think you have to replace a
black woman with a black woman so
Michelle Obama I don't know maybe I
I think Michelle I mean an election last
election or the white election before it
was Oprah is going to run right it's
always like Oprah Obama I just don't
think any of that is going to happen now
maybe I'm wrong but I don't see it by
the way Ned Biden his approval rating is
really low as well but they're trying to
spin it watch yeah
he had a truly historic rate of success
when it comes to Major economic programs
that are building the foundation and the
infrastructure for America to lead the
world not just in Innovation but in
manufacturing in the number of jobs
we've created in exports again people
are starting to feel that now
Ned he just vetoed the tariffs on solar
panels what he's from Manufacturing
this is epic gaslighting I mean what are
we talking about historic rates of
inflation Unemployment uh violent crime
illegal immigration you know I even saw
something today Laura in which there are
many Americans who might be hitting a
retirement crisis because of of this
situation the bite Administration has
put us in and that they're now afraid
they might run out of money in their
retirement funds I mean this is the if
you want to talk about historic uh
numbers this is Biden's historic numbers
are terrible on a whole host of fronts
and I don't see his Fable favorability
ratings Rising which all leads me to
think
unless Republicans figure out how to
actually collect more ballots I think
Biden still has a chance of winning
though in 2024 if he is the nominee well
I don't know Trump's speech over the
weekend about jobs in the economy and
EVS I mean we should all be talking
about the economy 24 7. Ned thank you I
think so too hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else